Ngày Mepong, tháng 1228, trên thông gà cô bộ video trên thế, bởi tay cơ quyền sự an thành 2 giời súng trong trạy vình như vậy đời,
phí công dưỡng như đã cố gắng điều khiến Mepai để thích khắc quay cùng để hướng ra xa khu vực giân cử.
Các bạn vỡ giời súng hộ chuyến nước U-Foss Còn, được tin thỏa ở vị trí các bờ 1,5 mấy mẹ tỏ rộ sâu năm nay.
Trưa đó, bằng vì mình chỉ tháng 1228, bởi tay cơ an thành 2 gà mà.
giời súng khu vực không cộng về ở vần làng ý văn cô vô thục tình ý và lồ vô.
Chong nước đăng bây thử dịm xó quả trình xử trước, toàn bộ bệnh vui trên mấy bây đều thiệt mạ.
Theo chuyển thông, mấy nhân tên hạnh khó khả năng là xe xóc trong quá trình xử trước,
giờ trước đám bởi của đều tra hình xử liên quan khả năng sẽ ra vì phạm trong quy định về trình bị trước chuyến mấy.
Bởi tại cơ hẳng nặng án hành hài được tích kế và chỉ tạo dưới thời liên xô.
Tính đến nay, án hành hài vẫn là mấy bây xử dụng đồng cơ tù biên kánh quật lớn nhất thế giới.
Giống án hành hài được biến trẻ cho quân đội liên xô tự nămu nhìn chính trăm xói mi chính.
Lưu đánh giá thao dều khả năng chuyến trở hẳng quá cơ lớn,
mang được khoảng số mi tính hẳng hẳng quật đá hai chăm chỉ mấy hài quân nhìn.
Trong đòo có khả hệ thống tên lượng hoàn trình và phương tiện quân sự hẳng nặng.
Mấy bây có thể cất hả cánh tại các sinh bây giá chính lưu cần thiệt.